busy night over there many people expect
virgin hotels opening to positively
impact all that surrounding area there
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
talked with businesses about their new
neighbor
as virgin hotels welcomes guests inside
nearby businesses
anticipate a boost in business
i think we'll see a lot more than we
ever seen with them
anticipation and excitement from strip
mall shops
shoot we're going to close at six just
to go check them out mark edwards
manages
undefeated a shoe boutique across the
street from the hotel
you got the clothes and shoes stuff that
you can't see or you don't see often
he says the new addition on the block
may help turn around the area
it's been slow very slow very slow uh
not just with this
pandemic but prior to that it was a
little bit more slower than normal
do you expect business to increase with
virgin hotels now opening
most definitely of course yes it brings
people to the area
gino ferraro owns ferraro's italian
restaurant
he predicts sales increasing between
seven and ten percent
following a temporary shutdown for five
months so we're excited to be here and
excited that the hotel is opening up
across the street
adding two businesses rebounding and
reopening
las vegas i think everything will be
straight and
i wish nothing but the best for both of
them and us with the hotel now
open and pandemic restrictions easing
businesses tell me they now see a light
at the end of the tunnel reporting in
las vegas kristin drummond 8 news now